suppose I look at the registry of
residents of my town and pick a person
at random what is the probability that
this person is under 18 years of age the
answer is about 25% suppose now that I
told you that this person is married
will you give the same answer of course
not the probability of being less than
18 years old is now much smaller what
happened here
we started with some initial
probabilities that reflect what we know
or believe about the world but we then
acquired some additional knowledge some
new evidence for example about this
person's family situation this new
knowledge should cause our beliefs to
change and the original probabilities
must be replaced by new probabilities
that take into account the new
information these revised probabilities
are what we call conditional
probabilities and this is the subject of
this lecture we will start with a formal
definition of conditional probabilities
together with the motivation behind this
particular definition we will then
proceed to develop three tools that rely
on conditional probabilities including
the Bayes rule which provides a
systematic way for incorporating new
evidence into a probability model the
three tools that we introduced in this
lecture involve very simple and
elementary mathematical formulas yet
they encapsulate some very powerful
ideas it is not an exaggeration to say
that much of this class will revolve
around the repeated application of
variations of these three tools to
increasingly complicated situations in
particular the Bayes rule is the
foundation for the field of inference it
is a guide on how to process data and
make inferences about unobserved
quantities or phenomena as such it is a
tool that is used all the time all over
science and engineering